the Marvel Cinematic Universe has
exploded post-end game with tons more
content in infinite directions but how
does the new stuff hold up against old
classics as we head into phase 5. this
is every MCU movie released so far
ranked
Theory 2013's the dark world has
everything you could want in practice
though it's just not very fun Chris
Hemsworth is as Charming as ever and
it's based in part on one of the
greatest comic book runs of all time
it's got a Star Wars style attack on
Asgard by spaceships flown by dark elves
it has the rock monsters from Thor's
very first Comics appearance thorned
Loki team up for revenge against the
villain that killed their mom climaxing
in a fist fight in which Thor and
malekith are literally punching each
other so hard that they land in other
dimensions unfortunately while all of
that sounds good on paper it's actually
both super boring and generally
confusing
when Nick Fury showed up at the end of
Iron Man and hinted at the idea of a
full-on shared Universe of superhero
movies fans were thrilled and then the
Incredible Hulk hit theaters a month
later to prove you should really be
careful what you wish for it's not that
the film is terrible but it's something
almost worse forgettable which is a real
shame when you consider that it does so
much right for one thing if you're going
to make a movie about a nerdy scientist
with anger issues so powerful they could
level a whole town getting the guy who
starred in Fight Club to play Bruce
Banner is a pretty solid move for
another the filmmakers realized
audiences didn't need a full-blown
origin story to get up to speed tying
the Hulk's origin into Captain America
and the super soldier program was the
first stumbling step toward building the
full-on shared Universe in the end
though it just didn't quite lend
critics praised director Chloe Jones
eternals for its inclusivity and
ambition but story-wise it didn't live
up to the hype unlike the vast majority
of MCU movies eternals is a little too
much like homework with more than a
dozen new heroes and villains the film
feels somehow overstuffed and Meandering
at the same time despite some big names
in front of and behind the camera this
Cosmic epic turned out undercooked
discussions over whose fault that is
will likely continue for some time the
general consensus in the Hollywood
trades was that Oscar winner Zhao was
hamstrung by having to adhere to
Marvel's strict formula while it teases
some exciting future projects eternals
on its own is a convoluted mess that
ranks embarrassingly low in the MCU
standings you are so pathetic Sam
Rockwell literally dancing across the
stage to present his army of Iron Man
drones is endlessly delightful but there
there's a lot in this movie that doesn't
involve Justin Hammer busting a move and
that's where it feels to measure up
hammer and Whiplash both serve as evil
versions of Tony Stark bringing
unnecessary complications to the story
even worse the scene when Stark goes
down into his basement with a particle
accelerator to somehow build a new
element might be the goofiest thing in
the entire MCU and those movies have a
talking raccoon from space at the same
time Iron Man 2 was a confident stride
towards the full MCU introducing the
Black Widow and War Machine and even
teasing Thor's arrival in the next film
there's a lot there to like and even if
it's outweighed by the bad stuff we'll
always have Justin Hammer's dance moves
Iron Man 2 might have been the first big
step toward fleshing out the Marvel
Universe but Thor was the first time we
actually got to see its scope in action
with Thor we got Asgard in all its Glory
complete with a rainbow laser Bridge
epic battles against Frost Giants and
perhaps most importantly those big old
Jack Kirby hats that Norse gods
apparently love to wear it even gave us
a viking God robot with a face made of
death lasers and it introduced arguably
the best villain in the whole MCU Loki
like Thor the Dark World though the
original Thor film somehow ended up
feeling like less than the sum of its
parts it should have been great but
ended up merely okay
Iron Man 3 trying to do something
different and it succeeded brilliantly
unfortunately what it was trying to do
was defy Expectations by completely
undermining everything fans loved about
Iron Man in the MCU Iron Man 3 explores
how the smartest guy in the room deals
with living in a world that's becoming
something that he can't predict it's a
movie about a superhero with an anxiety
disorder which results in Iron Man
spending the entire movie not wanting to
be Iron Man and thus being Iron Man as
little as possible plus there was the
whole fig Mandarin thing which some
people love but most fans were either
confused or disappointed by director
Shane black deserves credit for his bold
Vision which made for a good movie just
not a good Marvel movie
when 2016's Doctor Strange was announced
the big question for Comics fans was how
the mind-bending Psychedelic sorcery of
the mystical Marvel Universe was going
to fit into the MCU as Comics fans know
things get pretty weird
and from a visual standpoint the
filmmaker's absolutely nailed it the
splitting realities in the movie's fight
scenes were beautifully weird and the
Ghostly ethereal plane where life and
death battles for the fate of the earth
could rage unseen was great for showing
how different Stephen Strange's world
was from a story standpoint though it
seemed a little too familiar as the
story beats were basically Iron Man with
magic still you can do worse than
copying one of the most popular
superhero films ever and the Fantastic
climax with Strange's time-bending
bargain with dormammu is one of the best
finales in the MCU to date
juggling a massive cast of superheroes
is a difficult task and while Avengers
Age of Ultron doesn't manage it quite as
well as the other three Avengers films
or Captain America Civil War it does a
pretty good job of balancing character
bits with all-out action sure some parts
seem half-baked like Tony Stark
apparently forgetting every lesson he
learned in Iron Man 3 and Thor's weird
Spirit Quest but it boasts a great final
battle not to mention the introduction
of fan favorite characters vision and
the Scarlet Witch Avengers Age of Ultron
isn't perfect but it still packs in a
lot of fun
all the way back in 2010 producer Kevin
feige confirmed that a solo outing for
Natasha Romanov was in the pipeline but
over a decade would pass before Black
Widow hit cineplexes and Disney plus
taking place right after the events of
Captain America Civil War Kate
shortland's prequel sends Natasha back
to Budapest to deal with her past there
she teams up with Elena Bulova a fellow
Red Room trainee who once posed as
romanov's sister to take down the Black
Widow program watching Romanov right her
wrongs after so many years is undeniably
satisfying and black widow benefits from
the fact that it largely stands alone
it's a gripping watch and a worthy
send-off for an OG Avenger like the
this this thing that you do when you
whip your hair when you're fighting with
the is Thor love and thunder as good as
Thor Ragnarok no is it still a
rollicking good time you bet where else
are you going to see Chris Hemsworth
fight evil aliens to the rocking tunes
of Guns and Roses where else are you
going to see two giant screaming goats
pull a Viking ship along a magic rainbow
where else are you going to see Russell
Crowe Hamming it up as the Greek God
Zeus nowhere except in this mad wild
world that director Taiko with Titi has
created Thor may have lost all the
weight he gained after infinity War but
he's still missing something huge love
enter Jane Foster Thor's Old Flame
recently imbued with the power of
mjolnir now there are two thores running
around making nervous eyes at each other
wondering if they can take a second shot
at their relationship or if putting
themselves out there again is too
emotionally risky plus there's a deity
slang madman named core the guy odd
Butcher on the loose looking to get
revenge for his dead Daughter by living
up to his very evocative nickname sure
not every joke in love and thunder lands
yeah sometimes it gets a bit too zany
for its own good but when the jokes do
land they are hilarious and for the
first time in Thor history the
relationship between Jane Foster and the
God of Thunder actually works and
Natalie Portman absolutely shines in the
role of Mighty Thor
the first Guardians of the Galaxy movie
proved that the MCU could get weird and
Cosmic and still be incredibly
entertaining the second one proved that
it wasn't a fluke if anything it went
bigger the first movie brought us stuff
like the Nova Corps and Ronan the
Accuser but Volume 2 has about a half
hour of superheroes battling ego The
Living Planet it's got waves of space
drones swarming into Starship panels a
warp drive sequence that knows exactly
how silly it is and it features the best
Stan Lee cameo in cinema history and the
single best use of a Zune in anything
ever
it's tempting to say Ant-Man shouldn't
have worked as well as it did and that a
second tier superhero with the ability
to get really tiny and talk to ants was
a big surprise when it started to rake
in hundreds of millions of dollars
really though it's not that unexpected
after all Marvel's first big movie
success came from a pretty obscure
d-lister from the pages of Tomb of
Dracula audiences have always been
interested in stories that twist the
expected superhero plot points around in
something new and that's where Ant-Man
really delivers as easy as it would have
been to portray Scott Lang as a
microscopic version of Iron Man his
story felt different hey we look good
guys yeah what are the good guys right
yeah we're the good guys
it's kind of kind of weird you know
the movie has its missteps like going
out of its way to justify not having the
WASP show up until the sequel but on the
other hand this is a movie in which
chekhov's gun is actually chekhov's 60
ton tank
that the Avengers works at all is pretty
impressive but that it works as well as
it did that's basically a miracle even
less than a decade later it's difficult
to remember that this was the first time
that anything like this had been
attempted a movie that combined
characters who had been established in
their own films each with their own tone
and style in bringing them together Joss
Whedon had to balance the fantasy of
Thor the snarky sci-fi of Iron Man and
the sincere super heroics of Captain
America combining them all along with
all kakai and black widow with Stakes
that were high enough to bring everyone
together for a single adventure and this
movie does it those big Stakes mostly
result from an army of faceless aliens
but even that paid off years later in
Avengers Infinity war and Loki getting
Hulk smashed like a Looney Tunes
character was the most fun superhero
movies had ever been
it's safe to say Iron Man surprised us
all it's not that we expected it to be
bad Tony Stark's origin story is a
pretty good fit for a Hollywood action
movie it had a great cast and while
director John Favreau might have been
best known for Elf that really wasn't a
bad thing but still none of us expected
it to be so good that it would become
the foundation of the entire MCU to say
that it was an exceptionally powerful
launch would be an understatement there
are times when this feels less like a
superhero movie and more like a popcorn
Revenge flick where the hero just
happens to have a flying suit of armor
but it did its job so well that those
shortcomings are easy to forgive
every set piece in Ant-Man and the WASP
plays with the idea of changing size
from the WASP running along the blade of
a knife to Ant-Man using a flatbed truck
as a scooter through it all this sequel
is genuinely hilarious after the
Relentless Downer of Avengers Infinity
War this light-hearted take on
superheroes with Stakes far more
personal than Cosmic was a welcome tone
shift
what are you laughing please can you
just okay okay arguably the best thing
about the MCU is that it feels like a
shared Universe in the same way that the
comics do the knowledge that Ant-Man and
the wasp and infinity War happened at
roughly the same time is maybe the best
expression of that Thanos is solemnly
searching for the Infinity Stones while
Scott Lang is running through an
elementary school in a hoodie because he
got stuck at three feet tall and it all
sets up a heck of a gut punch at the end
six years after his original outing the
sorcerer's Supreme finally got his own
sequel with Doctor Strange in the
Multiverse of Madness directed by the
legendary Sam Raimi in keeping with many
of Remy's earlier Works Multiverse of
Madness is a tale tinged with horror
here strange must use all his powers to
protect America Chavez a young girl with
the ability to portal between universes
but only when she's truly terrified and
as it turns out America is scared for a
pretty good reason the murderous
unhinged Scarlet Witch the movie is a
Trippy journey into Terror but it's not
all about scares Multiverse of Madness
is also fun bringing in a ton of great
cameos showing glimpses of weird new
worlds and letting strange really
explore his magical abilities Dark Yet
never too dark the good doctors sequel
is just as strange as we were all hoping
it would be
the First Avenger does origin stories
better than most and a lot of that has
to do with Chris Evans in a franchise
that's full of amazing casting choices
Evans pulls off the incredible feat of
embodying a square jawed relentlessly
Earnest product of the military
industrial complex in a way that makes
him impossible not to like for all that
super strength there's a character who's
real superpower is making you believe in
him and that's exactly what this movie
does I'm gonna do this all day
as good as it was on its own it also
serves as the proof of concept for the
superhero movie as a period piece and
gave the MCU a history that went further
back than 2008 and Tony Stark's cave
the first Guardians of the Galaxy movie
manages to balance so much stuff going
on that you almost don't notice how
complicated it is for all the fun you're
having it's got a team of lovable
Misfits dealing with their own issues
while fighting against a massive threat
expansive Interstellar Empires and a
retrofuel supported by a classic rock
soundtrack that doesn't feel like it's
wallowing in the past all that and still
tells a story so fun that it made Rocket
Raccoon a household name it breaks the
formula in every way it can to the point
where it's a superhero T movie that ends
with a dance off and the heroes
literally saving the universe with the
power of friendship
far from home is built around the
question of what this universe looks
like without its first superhero Tony
Stark there's a void in the MCU that
needs to be filled and Spider-Man might
just be the one to do it that's why
Mysterio's plot goes all the way back to
the first Iron Man film and weaves
through the entire MCU timeline making
it all make sense to cap off another
phase of the MCU was an amazing feat all
the good Spider-Man stuff is here Peter
Parker has to wrestle with
responsibility and self-doubt the
romance with MJ's heartfelt and Suite
and there are serious consequences for
Spider-man always walking around with
his mask off there are World shattering
surprises and lots of fun special
effects from a special effects wizard
villain it's a super fun time at the
movie theater
there were some pretty heavy
expectations for Captain Marvel given
that it was the mcu's first film led by
a woman luckily it succeeded Big Time
rather than falling into the tried and
true Iron Man formula that had been used
to introduce so many other MCU
characters Captain Marvel was a search
for identity that search took place over
the backdrop of an Intergalactic war
with the title character's potential
mostly represented by the main character
glowing with literal Cosmic fire while
she punched her way through spaceships
at times Captain Marvel may come off as
a little corny but that corniness is a
result of Simply being very Earnest and
heartfelt and at times inspiring my name
is Carol
between that the cosmic action and lots
of jokes about the 90s it lived up to
the hype
the tragic loss of Chadwick Boseman
looms large over wakanda forever the
movie opens with news that Bozeman's
iconic character t'challa has passed
away but wakanda forever isn't just a
tearjerker it's also funny exciting and
action-packed director Ryan coogler is
on his A-game here creating an enjoyable
superhero film and honoring Bozeman
Leticia Wright and Angela Bassett are
also phenomenal as t'challa's royal
family one assumes their tears aren't
just acting and while Bozeman's presence
is missed these two provide the
emotional strength we all need in the
late actor's absence of course the real
seamstealer here is tenoch Huerta as
Namor the Submariner the perfect foil
for shuri like her he's also lost his
family he also knows what it's like
having foreign forces invading her
Homeland something wakanda has been
dealing with since t'challa's death
while we question his methods we never
question his motives as for sure
yourself the movie bookends with the
hero grappling with her brother's death
on one side resisting on one side
accepting it's a truly beautiful
transformation in a genuinely Beautiful
film everything about the Winter Soldier
reinforces the idea that Captain America
is exactly the guy you want to have the
power to save the world the notebook
full of Pop Culture references that he
needs to look up to understand the world
around him the friendship with Sam
Wilson that starts with bonding over
their wartime experience the loyalty to
his friends that leads him to risk his
own life to save Bucky he even gives his
opponents one last chance to back out
before he beats up an elevator full of
traitors all of these pieces add up to a
hole that's incredible even before you
get to how much of the movie is based
around Steve Rogers just kicking the
living hell out of bad guys that stuff's
pretty fun too
Marvel's ultimate goal with Xiang Chi
and the legend of the 10 Rings was to
repeat the success of black panther
according to deadline and that plan
largely worked with critics agreeing it
was a solid step toward better Asian
representation in Hollywood shanxi
doesn't stray very far from Marvel's
tried and tested origin story formula
but it sets itself apart when it comes
to action director Destin Daniel
cretin's movie pays homage to the fight
choreography of Jackie Chan as well as
Chinese martial arts films past and
present simulyu brings the Perfect Blend
of humility and heroism to the title
role while Aquafina Tony Leung and
Michelle yo are all on their a-games too
add in a couple of unexpected cameos and
you're on to a winner
[Applause]
even though Steve Rogers and Bucky
Barnes are unquestionably the focus of
Civil War there's a pretty convincing
argument to be made that this movie
should have been called Avengers Civil
War instead it has everyone in it and
they aren't just cameos either Ant-Man
Hawkeye Scarlet Witch and War Machine
all get huge character developing
moments in the middle of a super heroic
Royal Rumble while the Avengers are
split by a villain who wound up getting
exactly what he wanted and if that
wasn't enough it's also the movie that
introduced movie audiences to Black
Panther and Spider-Man the characters
are never flattened out to fit and the
three-way fight at the end has not only
some of the best action in the MCU but
some of the most emotional moments too
after his debut in Civil War t'challa's
first Solo movie came with some pretty
high expectations not only did it live
up to them it blew right past them for
one of the mcu's best movies maybe it's
because Chadwick boseman's t'challa is a
character struggling with the weight of
expectations himself black panther is
more than up to the challenge but the
journey he takes to get there is full of
compelling complications from the reveal
that his father wasn't the flawlessly
honorable man that he thought to an
enemy with some very justifiable anger
at the world around him it's a superhero
struggle that goes far beyond just the
punch-out battle in the climax black
panther never shines away from its
high-tech comic book Roots but tells a
story that's very much rooted in the
real world and does it beautifully
more than any other superhero movie
Infinity War captures the feeling of an
epic comic book crossover there are
multiple interconnected stories going on
at the same time each with its own
flavor bridging different story arcs and
making sure every single character gets
a moment in the spotlight when it comes
together at the end it's a fight across
multiple planets where the unbelievably
high stakes become very real for both
the characters and the fans who have
been invested in these movies for a full
10 years that's a tough enough bit of
Storytelling to pull off well even in
comic books and they've had Decades of
practice seeing it done here in a single
movie that still has the feeling of
encompassing a whole universe no other
movie has ever done that and it's hard
to imagine another one doing it this
well
as good as it is on its own the fact
that Peter Parker swings into action
after 15 other movies means we don't
have to waste time with an origin story
thematically homecoming Builds on
everything that came before in a truly
incredible way with direct callbacks to
Tony Stark's character Arc that show how
different Peter is from the hero he's
trying to impress the idea of a
superhero Universe erupting around
otherwise normal people is the conflict
that drives everything about the movie
take that away and you've still got
great characters great action and one of
the best scenes in the franchise with it
though you've got Pure Magic
to say that Ragnarok lifts heavily from
Walt Simonson's epic mid-80s run of the
Mighty Thor is putting it mildly the
only things in this movie that weren't
directly inspired by Simonson are the
pieces it pulls directly from Marvel's
more recent Planet Hulk storyline right
down to the Hulk's Gladiator gear the
thing is taika watiti's film chops up
all those pieces and rearranges them
into something that's both different and
genuinely hilarious that part isn't
surprising considering that before
Ragnarok ytt was probably best known for
co-directing the vampire mockumentary
what we do in the shadows but it takes
advantage of Chris Hemsworth's
infuriatingly good comedic timing
ow just had to be sure
three generations of Spider-Man movies
Collide spectacularly in Spider-Man no
way home Tom Holland's Peter Parker is
once again the main focus but no way
home is closer to an Avenger style team
up than the two films that precede it Dr
Strange plays a huge role but some
characters from outside the MCU show up
too in what was one of the worst kept
secrets in MCU history Toby Maguire and
Andrew Garfield appear to offer Hollens
Peter Parker Sage advice and much needed
comfort in the fight to save the lives
of the villains from those two actors
own Spider-Man flicks Holland finally
gets his with great power comes great
responsibility moment and it's one that
you won't forget the Brit turns in his
most accomplished performance as Spidey
backed up by the All-Star Supporting
Cast no way home is the best Spider-Man
movie to date
end game could have gone wrong really
easily it's meant to serve as the climax
of the 21 movies before it in the first
Saga of the MCU so saying that Marvel
pulled it off is saying that they pretty
much achieved a miracle the film is
loaded with callbacks in ways that you
don't even realize until you stop to
think about them Captain America's
support group new Asgard Black Widow
wiping out the red in her Ledger and the
list goes on it's payoff after payoff
but it never feels like pure fan service
it really does feel like an ending plus
end game has plenty of great moments on
its own the time travel hijinks the
debut of Professor Hulk The Audacity of
skipping ahead five years and the sheer
fist pumping awesomeness of cap
tightening up his shield and standing
alone against the apocalypse it really
is the Thundering climax fans have
wanted from the start is that everyone
like you wanted more
[Music]